to like
set the tone like are there certain
things that guys can do to set the tone
to lead the frame in a relationship
i'd say that just with uh opening on
dating apps you can set frame with that
if you
open up too nice they're going to put
you in that you know friend zone
resource category right you got to come
at them you know you can't be vulgar or
whatever but i i come
straight at them with like i'm in the
king stop i'm looking for dates that are
into king stuff
yeah i'm here for you know there's sex
is number one thing i'm talking about
right off the gate
it doesn't have to be completely about
that you know i don't go into details
i like kink stuff so are you interested
if they are
like a conversation proceeds from there
but i've already set the pace that hey
this is a sexual
relationship we're talking about right
here yeah
yeah absolutely and actually i'd say
it's really important it's really
important to do that
in the early stages of a dating sexual
relationship
i think a lot of guys don't give
themselves permission to be in control
of the frame in the first place
and this is as a result i think of the
acculturation and socialization and
whatever like
last like three or four generations of
guys is
they are not expecting to be in control
of the frame
they they believe in this egalitarian
equalist
ideal and that we're all going to be
even steven and so
uh just like it goes it like permeates
everything all of our relationships when
it comes to uh well i mean other people
too but like certainly
when it comes to uh intersectional
dynamics uh just like what
myron was saying just a second ago it's
like you're on a date or something like
that
and now you've gone from okay we're
gonna go to this restaurant we're gonna
go do this we're gonna like you have
you have a plan you have some some sort
of direction you have some sort of goal
you have some sort of like okay this is
what we're gonna do on this date i'm in
control
i'm gonna drive the car kind of thing
and then what happens is when you go
from that
to i don't know what do you want to do i
don't know what do you want to do
then suddenly now you've lost the frame
because you are deferring to
her authority as far as like what it is
that you want to do and where you want
to go
and so now not only have you sort of
maybe willingly or voluntarily like you
know surrendered the frame to the whole
thing
um you've gone from being in control and
in
as a command presence is like troy was
saying just a second ago you've gone
from being a command presence to being
like okay let's play this
whole even and what happens is when you
do something like that
you go from being this guy who's
competent and this guy who
is dominant and competent enough to like
have a plan and do all these things
and giving off this vibe of okay this
guy's alpha and i
i say that in abstract terms um
to being sort of like you don't know
what you're doing you become
incompetent all of a sudden and what
that does is it triggers
in a woman it triggers the idea that oh
my god this guy
he almost tricked me he almost fooled me
i thought he was alpha all this time
and now he's deferring to my authority
now he's deferring to me
now now suddenly he's gone from being in
command
and having frame to giving it up
willingly
it's not like she tried to test him and
take it from him the guy just didn't
give himself permission to stay and
maintain it and stay in control of that
now that's in a dating sense that's not
in a long-term sense just so when you've
got a
a woman who believes that you are in
control and she
goes you know she wants to live in the
world that you're creating that's really
what the early puas used to say it was
like frame was
the world into which that woman wants to
be a part of like she willingly comes
and voluntarily comes
and lives within your world in your
frame and now suddenly you're going well
you know sorry it was all [ __ ] uh it
was all me just kind of faking this the
whole time
and now we're gonna play even steven and
now it's 50 50 and i want to know what
you want to do and let's you know your
needs are important and this is and this
and this and this and this you know
let's have open communication all this
other stuff instead of this being my
frame and this being my world
what happens is that triggers her sort
of existential fear that says
this guy really doesn't know what he's
doing and oh my god
i'm invested in this guy how am i going
to
extricate myself from this situation and
i just want to um
go ahead and i'll help you hey um cause
roller brought up a really good point
there
maintaining frame inequality cannot
coexist you know
and and quite frankly a lot of women
believe in this bs
ideology that you know men and women are
equal blah blah blah i mean i get it all
the time on my tick tock
like you're a massager that's all that
man we could don't you want an equal
partnership and i'm here to tell you
dumb broads like
no not at all because at the end of the
day men lead women follow in women i
always say women are inc
fundamentally incapable of leading men
within any confinement of a relationship
so in order for the relationship to work
there's got to be one person running it
you know nothing gets done by committee
there's a reason why we have a president
united states there's a prime minister
whatever
when there's a committee it makes things
a lot more difficult to come to a solid
decision quickly
so um maintaining frame and equality
can't coexist
let me just um chime in here because i
wanted to talk about this um
you know as the early steps because i
also want to also catch up with these
super chats and i want to move into more
like long-term relationship frame but
a really good way to kind of check this
from the get-go is when you're setting
up a date with a chick you're always
going to meet somewhere right
conventionally i mean there's some
places that are still on lockdown but
let's say conventionally
you're going to get through a meat you
know for a coffee a drink a meal
whatever
it should always be a coffee or drink
you know for the first one you know from
the get-go by the way
but you've got to travel she's at point
a
you're at point b are you going to go to
point a is she going to come to point b
are you going to meet in the middle the
thing with that is
i've seen women drive three hours on a
first date and come right to my front
door
i've also conventionally had women say
well no i don't have a car
and i live all the way downtown so i
need you to come to
this place that's at the bottom of my
building if i'm gonna drive
all the way downtown from the toronto
suburbs to go to her front door
i'm in her frame if she can't get on an
uber or find a way to meet me somewhere
that i
that i pinpoint then she's not
cooperating and that's ideally going to
be a waste of my time and that's not an
indicator of genuine burning desire
if you're going to get engaged in
anything on any kind of basis
it's always my opinion that you want
genuine burning desire from her if you
want her best
and a real good test of that frame is to
make sure that she's gonna come
somewhere in the middle at the very
least if not right to your front door
would be ideal
that's a very very good indicator of
holding the frame in that dynamic let me
just grab these super chats real quick
before we keep moving on here tom
those are great by the way thanks man
uh tom will come come from far far away
if they really want to be with oh yeah
yeah and if she's not interested in you
she's going to make you drive to her
front door because she's got nothing
better going on that night right
uh tom bombadil says good morning uh don
says when's rola coming to miami um
myron do you want to chime in on that
uh he's gonna be here on monday and then
we'll do the show we're debating whether
we're gonna do it on tuesday or
wednesday but i'm thinking tuesday we'll
do the show rollo we're going to talk
about his book
uh and then we'll have him in hotep on
on wednesday cool
nice that'll be fun to watch and we got
another one here from tom
50 super chat we are done mincing words
christians will win the coming conflict
the battle of good versus evil it's not
even close
choose this day who you will serve step
out and be counted good or evil god or
satan thanks last time somebody said
that [ __ ] he ended up on a [ __ ] rap
sheet
just saying yeah
it's good to have these feelings but a
lot of this just turns out to
be guys sitting on their butt hoping and
praying that something will happen
somebody's gonna do something somebody
else is gonna do something
here's a here's a very good example of a
frame rate like i've had a girl drive
two hours to come see me brought me
breakfast too
right like that's that's that's one
she's got genuine burning desire for you
and if you don't know what that is read
my book
and two she's obviously in your frame
well
i mean women break rules for alphas and
they make rules for betas that's the
if you want to know whether or not you
have frame like do i have friend
i get this all the time some guys like
emailing me stuff like i lost frame i
did this i did
and and now i have to do these things or
i have to jump through these hoops or
whatever else it's like if
she is making rules for
you i don't know how how much more
simple i can put this
if she's making rules she does not see
you're not in her frame
if you are obeying those rules if you're
going okay we're gonna
spoon on the couch for you know for
for uh you know two hours before we even
move on to doing anything else if she's
the one that is
giving you the rules and saying well you
know and you know we're it's it's the
third date fourth date fifth day eighth
date tenth date whatever it is you know
i
i just don't feel comfortable with you
blah blah blah
she's making rules for you ask yourself
the very simple question
am i jumping through hoops am i obeying
rules is she making rules and am i
following them
or is she breaking rules is she changing
religions is she
you know blowing off her friends because
she is
that into me is that's because
just like what you're saying before like
rachel of course you know you can't
negotiate a
genuine desire uh john you're just
saying a minute ago it's like if
if she is into if she's a ride-or-die
girl if she has genuine desire for you
she will
break rules to get with you right
that's how you definitely that's why
because women want that that alpha male
right they want that dominance
in there and like i was saying before
with uh i've said this before with uh
with donovan is that if a woman is into
you she will suddenly find things to
be to have in common with you she will
she will grow her hair long she'll
change her style
she'll take out an iud she'll even
tattoo her name on your body if she's
that much
indie if she's in your head i had a girl
first date she drove five hours
to meet me in uh san luis obispo
for the weekend great
greatest first date ever great first
date ever
words words from an mma champ right
you